[Applauso]
basta uno schermo come quello dei vostri
smartphone e due semplici lenti davanti
a questo schermo per dare al nostro
cervello l'illusione di trovarsi in un
altro posto lontano anche fuori da
questo coro oggi chiunque di voi seduto
comodamente su queste poltrone potrebbe
indossare questo visore di realtà
virtuale e trasferirsi in un altro
scenario in un altro posto ad esempio
sulla stazione spaziale internazionale
dove guardarsi attorno
vedere tutto da un'altra prospettiva
guardare il nostro pianeta blu da
lontano tutto questo sarebbe reso
possibile solamente da un'illusione
ottica
oggi la realtà virtuale è uno strumento
capace di portarci davvero lontano è un
teletrasporto per la nostra mente capace
di regalarci dei viaggi fatti di bit di
pixel ma di cui ci riportiamo indietro
delle memorie come se l'avessimo vissute
in prima persona
ora tutti quanti facciamo dei viaggi con
la nostra mente per curiosità per
fantasia
lo facciamo per gioco ma ci sono dei
momenti in cui viaggiare con la mente è
una necessità
serve per superare delle condizioni
difficilissime delle situazioni che ci
sembrano fuori controllo
allora vi chiederei per un attimo di
mettere da parte la tecnologia di
dimenticare il bisogno di realtà
virtuale e utilizzare uno dei nostri
super poteri biologici che chiamiamo
immaginazione e immaginate che invece di
me e di questo palcoscenico vi trovate
davanti a un posto che nella maggior
parte dei casi tutti noi vorremmo
evitare un ospedale
immaginate quindi di parcheggiare vicino
a questo ospedale di entrare
dall'entrata principale di percorrere i
suoi corridoi di vedere tantissimi
pazienti i parenti che li aiutano di
vedere i medici da
nelle nostre attività è un certo punto
percorrete questi corridoni rivedete
delle porte chiuse altre aperte è un
certo punto entrate in una camera una
camera in cui probabilmente vedrete un
eletto massimo due e una finestra che
raramente si affaccia su un bellissimo
panorama
ecco in una camera di questo tipo
potreste vedere un bambino
flavio che noi abbiamo incontrato
assieme a tantissimi altri bambini
lavorando con ospedali e associazioni
seduto o sdraiato nel posto più lontano
e con l'espressione più innaturale che
rispetta che non è per forza sofferenza
ma anche solo noia accettazione passiva
di una condizione più grande di lui
ecco la prima differenza forse più
scontata tra noi e flavio e che noi per
uscire da questa stanza d'ospedale
basta semplicemente non pensarci
cambiamo idea e siamo già fuori per
flavia non è così
flavio ha ricevuto una diagnosi ed è
stato ricoverato e quindi deve seguire
un percorso che fuori dal suo controllo
ecco proprio da questa stanza d'ospedale
assieme a flavio in questo in questa
camera vorrei partire oggi a parlarvi di
salute è sottolineare soprattutto come
salute non sia solamente uno stato
fisico una condizione fisica dei
risultati clinici positivi perché salute
e anche lo spazio che occupiamo e la
casa in cui viviamo è l'ufficio in cui
lavoriamo salute e anche lo stato
mentale con cui affrontiamo tutte le
nostre routine quotidiane le relazioni
le nostre passioni le nostre sfide
ecco nel caso di flavio tutta la sua
routine quotidiana
lo spazio che viveva prima è stato
sconvolto dalla terapia e dalla malattia
quindi a un certo punto la reazione di
flavio
probabilmente quella che sarebbe di
tutti noi al suo posto e cercare di
andare oltre quelle quattro mura cercare
di immaginarsi posti lontani diversi
usando proprio quella che stiamo usando
ma in questo momento l'immaginazione
cercando di sostituire delle emozioni
negative che è lo buttano giù con delle
emozioni positive che lo facciano stare
meglio che facciano sembrare tutto
questo più facile e più approcciabile
ecco noi abbiamo lavorato da due anni
con ospedali associazioni abbiamo visto
quanto sia importante supportare i
pazienti non solo dal punto di vista
fisico ma anche mentalmente cercando di
portare fuori la loro mente
dall'ospedale e queste realtà oggi in
questo mondo così tecnologico così
delocalizzato
al di là di tutte le attività che hanno
organizzato finora hanno dei nuovi
alleati come appunto la realtà virtuale
la realtà virtuale è una tecnologia che
troppo spesso associamo solamente al
gioco al all'intrattenimento al poter
incontrare persone dovunque siano nel
mondo ma ci dimentichiamo o non lo
sappiamo che la realtà virtuale può
essere utilizzata per cambiare in meglio
la qualità di vita dei pazienti negli
ospedali
una vita che da un'altra viene
supportata dalla terapia ma quando
parliamo di stress di ansia e di dolore
anche di depressione spesso queste
condizioni vengono trattate
farmacologicamente pensate in sedativi
agli antidolorifici che magari possono
sembrare delle soluzioni rapide
immediate efficace che neutralizzano il
paziente ma che non non contrastano non
risolvono realmente il trauma vissuto
dei pazienti un trauma che non interessa
il paziente solo durante la terapia ma
che avrà un impatto enorme anche anni
dopo che il paziente fortunato uscirà da
quell ospedale
allora quello che noi abbiamo fatto da
due anni circa con una realtà che ho
creato con i miei colleghi che si chiama
softwares furious è stato cercare di
esplorare quello che un gioco quello che
un intrattenimento questa tecnologia
della realtà virtuale
per capire come uno strumento digitale
non farmacologico e non invasivo potesse
aiutare a far crollare mura reali quelle
dell'ospedale è in questo lavoro siamo
riusciti a realizzare un primo progetto
che abbiamo chiamato tommy un gioco un
gioco
in realtà virtuale che coinvolge sia il
paziente di bambino sia il genitore
creando dei momenti che rappresentano in
un certo senso un oasi di rilassamento
un'oasi di distrazione dalle quattro
mura dell'ospedale mura che sono
diventate dei limiti per il corpo del
paziente ma anche per la sua mente
ora la realtà virtuale è una tecnologia
che si basa come vi dicevo prima su un
illusione ottica l'illusione che si
genera quando indossiamo un visore di
realtà virtuale per osservare scenari
virtuali digitali creati al computer ma
ha un impatto reale fisiologico sul
cervello e sulla nostra mente in un
certo senso potremmo chiamare la realtà
virtuale come un'iterazione tecnologica
moderna della nostra immaginazione e può
essere utilizzato come strumento
standard tecnologico per aiutare tutte
quelle condizioni in cui la nostra mente
deve poter immaginare un posto migliore
e diverso rispetto a quello in cui si
trova come nel caso di un bambino
flavio costretto su un letto in un
ospedale chiuso tra quattro mura come fa
la realtà virtuale ad avere questo
effetto come fa la realtà virtuale ad
aiutare flavio a superare questi limiti
lo può fare così come ha fatto con
tantissimi pazienti finora negli ultimi
decenni pensate che già negli anni 90
dei pionieri ricercatori come hunter
hoffman avevano utilizzato la realtà
virtuale per trattare dei pazienti poli
ustionati che venivano sottoposti a dei
trattamenti estremamente dolorosi come
la rimozione delle garze durante
la loro permanenza in ospedale una
situazione che era talmente dolorosa che
nemmeno gli oppiacei riuscivano ad
aiutarle bene hoffman con il suo gruppo
realizzo dei primi scenari in realtà
virtuale che chemos no words quindi
paesaggi innovate innevati e ghiacciati
che fornì a questi pazienti e vide che
all'improvviso questi pazienti non
sentivano più dolore
questi pazienti all'improvviso erano
molto meno sensibili al dolore e
riuscivano a completare questi
trattamenti
ovviamente potremo pensare una semplice
distrazione
io mi distraggo non penso al problema il
problema diventa più piccolo quindi più
approcciabile sì ma hoffmann fece
qualcos'altro
sapete che cosa riusciranno a fare i
dottori con un semplice scenario in
realtà virtuale dato dei pazienti
ustionati letteralmente riuscirono a
spegnere il dolore all'interno del
cervello dei pazienti realizzando delle
risonanze magnetiche quello che si
scoprì lì è che fondamentalmente i
centri del dolore all'interno del
cervello si spegnevano senza nessun
farmaco quello che fu utilizzato
fu un beat furono dei pixel a posto dei
farmaci e successivamente negli anni
successivi quindi negli anni 2000 fino a
oggi la realtà virtuale fu utilizzata
diverse volte anche per trattare ad
esempio i disturbi d'ansia le fobie
l'aracnofobia l'agorafobia la paura di
parlare in pubblico la paura di volare
questo perché comodamente seduti nella
loro poltrone tutte le persone possono
indossare un bisogno in realtà virtuale
e fondamentalmente fare l'esperienza di
uno scenario di cui hanno paura fare
l'esperienza di uno stimolo di cui hanno
paura approcciandosi a questo stimolo
avvicinandosi abituandosi a questo
stimolo superandolo e questo superamento
non è solo qualcosa che rimane nel mondo
virtuale ma che così che si consolida
anche in quello reale aiutando queste
persone a vivere più serenamente la loro
vita
successivamente la realtà virtuale venne
utilizzata anche per trattare persone
con disordini alimentari per esempio
proprio qui a milano grazie ai lavori
pionieristici
del dottor giuseppe riva la realtà
virtuale viene utilizzata per aiutare i
pazienti a correggere la visione non
corretta che hanno il proprio corpo e
delle proprie abitudini alimentari
ma perché la realtà virtuale riesce ad
avere questo effetto
pur essendo digitale questo lo dobbiamo
individuare nel modo in cui funziona la
nostra mente nella percezione
innanzitutto la percezione della realtà
è qualcosa che plasma la nostra visione
del mondo ma plasma anche il nostro
cervello cambia letteralmente la rete di
neuroni nel nostro cervello in un
processo chiamato neuroplasticità e allo
stesso tempo la percezione della realtà
quella che state percependo qui adesso
non è mai in diretta poi non state
percependo la realtà tutto quello che
percepite e immediato dai vostri sensi
esterni o interni quello che fa il
cervello
fondamentalmente è prendere informazioni
dell'esterno informazioni dall'interno e
creare una simulazione della realtà
quello che voi vedete è la simulazione
che possa cervello sta facendo del mondo
circostante una simulazione che viene
costruita con i dati del presente che
viene confrontata con i dati del passato
con la memoria e che serve per predire
in un certo senso il futuro in modo tale
che quando vi ritrovate davanti degli
stimoli
questi possono essere interpretati come
opportunità da cogliere
oppure pericoli da evitare questo porta
a chiamare questa simulazione come
modello predittivo il problema che
questo modello predittivo può essere
hackerato ci possono essere dei bug in
certo senso sensoriali per cui se
facciamo l'esperienza di traumi di
emozioni negative
questi traumi possono influenzare come
andremo a vivere le nostre esperienze
future vi faccio un esempio quello di
flavio quando proprio vivere
un'esperienza particolarmente dolorosa
un test clinico
ogni volta che si creeranno le
condizioni per vivere di nuovo quel test
flavio comincerà ad anticipare il dolore
che lo attende vivendo male malissimo le
settimane precedenti i giorni precedenti
e quando farà il test
riuscirà anche a sentire più dolore
rispetto a quello che ho sentito la
prima volta solo per un colpa di una
componente mentale
ecco la realtà virtuale in verità può
essere utilizzata perché in qualsiasi
stato di malessere fondamentalmente c'è
sempre una componente mentale che può
essere corretta
grazie a degli stimoli esterni che
possono essere forniti dalla realtà
virtuale
normalmente i nostri modelli predittivi
sono contro di noi
creano anche delle condizioni di
malessere per realtà virtuale può essere
utilizzata per consolidare degli stati
di benessere proattive ora benissimo la
realtà virtuale può essere utile nel
campo della salute per aiutare i
pazienti
ma cosa succederà in futuro quando la
realtà virtuale sarà ogni presente nelle
nostre case come i vostri smartphone
oggi cosa succederà quando da un lato
faremo l'esperienza di viaggi
divertimento di incontri da lontano ma
allo stesso tempo potremmo vivere delle
esperienze che sono state costruite ad
hoc per costruire diversamente le nostre
abitudini per farci fare delle scelte
politiche economiche o sociali diverse
da quelle che vogliamo
abbiamo gli anticorpi culturali per far
fronte a questo tipo di contenuti che
agiscono così profondamente livello
della nostra mente
ecco vorrei fare un piccolo esempio a
proposito della solidità della realtà è
una storia vera quella vissuta dal
dottor oliver sacks un neurologo di fama
internazionale che ebbe un paziente che
chiamo signor p
musicista di mezza età che viveva
tranquillamente la propria vita ma che a
un certo punto comincio ad avere
problemi nell'associare il significato
agli oggetti bene
l'esempio più lampante fu quando questo
paziente uscendo da una visita con il
dottor sax stava uscendo con la moglie e
poco prima della porta prese la testa
della moglie cercò di indossarla questo
perché aveva letteralmente scambiato la
testa della moglie per il suo cappello
lui vedeva la testa della moglie ma
capiva che era un cappello
quindi questa realtà che ci sembra così
solida e davvero così solida e davvero
così costante irripetibile
ecco nei prossimi anni delle tecnologie
digitali
erano sempre più un impatto sulla nostra
percezione vi faremo sempre più mix di
realtà virtuali e reali e quindi la
nostra routine sensoriale sarà sempre
più digitale cambiando letteralmente il
nostro cervello
ora in un mondo di questo tipo
siamo davvero capaci di distinguere
quali contenuti possono essere positivi
per noi e quali negativi siamo capaci di
prendere in considerazione la nostra
percezione sensoriale come qualcosa che
fa parte del nostro stato di salute
esattamente come oggi pensiamo una dieta
o uno stile di vita
oggi abbiamo imparato a mangiare meglio
ad avere degli stili di vita che
supportano la nostra salute ma in futuro
dobbiamo prestare attenzione a come
viene supportata la nostra percezione a
che tipo di contenuti esperienziale
attraverso gli strumenti digitale che ci
verranno forniti ecco oggi la realtà
virtuale viene utilizzata per supportare
flavio a uscire da quelle quattro mura
dell'ospedale un giorno se non la
teniamo d'occhio questo stesso strumento
potrebbe limitare flavio in altre mura
costruite da altri di natura politica
sociale economica senza chiedere alcun
permesso
[Applauso]